mr. president just I'm just gonna open
it up to you to go wherever you want
with this this has been something you've
had to deal with your entire presidency
almost you have were loud and saying it
was not true it was a witch hunt and we
had four separate investigations backing
up your claim and culminating what you
saw yesterday sir your your reaction all
that well I think people learned a lot
yesterday watching a very poor
performance and watching things that
they couldn't believe when they saw what
was going on and hopefully we're going
to be able to find out how a thing like
this started it was a disgrace to our
country it was a disgrace from every
standpoint and I would say that most
people have never seen anything like it
and then on top of it you watch that
performance it was it was shocking very
sad
how much of that did you watch sir say
it John how much of the Muller testimony
did you actually watch so I wasn't gonna
watch it all and then I started thinking
about it and then I watched a little bit
at the very beginning and I couldn't
believe what I was saying and I ended up
watching more than I wanted to and then
I watched the afternoon because you know
it was such a big crater at the
beginning and I said now I have to watch
I have to watch 50 shifts because he
just went through three hours and now he
has to go through shift and I said this
is gonna be very interesting and I've
never seen anything like it
actually it was sort of good television
so I couldn't watch it all I had
meetings I had economic development
meetings that are saying fellas maybe we
could move it to another time but I
didn't want to do that but I got to
watch enough and it was shocking I
thought the Republicans represented
themselves brilliantly actually John
Radcliffe and Jim Jordan and I mean all
of them Louie Gohmert I could mention 15
names it or however many they have that
spoke it got fairly close to that number
I guess maybe it was a little bit less
than that but I will tell you that
everybody representing the Republicans I
thought was really good and I thought
the other side was too
quickly biased but they were stuck with
a situation that they couldn't believe
mr. president I just mentioned the New
York Times not long ago actually said
that they believed that well the dossier
which you I was stunned mullet didn't
know about fusion GPS the things he
didn't know shocked me didn't know GT
reg Clinton's attorney work for him but
we'll put that aside but they suggested
at the New York Times that the dirty
dossier that Hillary paid for that was
used to spy on your campaign your
transition and even your presidency sir
was likely Russian disinformation from
the beginning now if that's the case
that would mean that the Russians knew
that Hillary was paying for those lies
which would mean that the narrative that
the American people have been fed by the
media and the Democrats that well they
were trying to help you the Russians
that would mean if the New York Times is
right for once and I suspect they may
very well be that they were trying to
hurt you more than Hillary well based on
the fact that we've just become and you
know fairly recently
a little while ago the number one oil
and gas producer an energy producer in
the world by far the Russia Saudi Arabia
now second and third based on the fact
that we now have the best we have a we
will soon have the most modern military
we have ever had with the best equipment
the best DUIs planes and all of the
things that we've done and and so many
other things Sean based on all of that
the last person they should want is me
but I have heard the same thing about
the fake dossier I've heard it came out
of Russia I think a lot of it also was
made up it was just made up out of like
you'd write a novel but it was a fake
and it was paid for by the Democrats and
paid for by Hillary Clinton and the DNC
and it's a it's incredible these are
incredible stories nobody would write a
novel like this because people wouldn't
believe it it wouldn't be believable you
know mr. president I famously vast
Lindsey Graham he he really went
Attorney General Barr was before his
mitii he went through a list of things
do you feel that mullah did a good job
that he have the resources do you
believe that his team had every
opportunity you turned over one and a
half million documents I can't believe
you encouraged everybody to testify
before Congress before the special
council like I was shocked McGann did
but we'll put that aside here and you
keep saying that you think we can't let
this happen again
and I guess the we've learned from the
attorney general that he's going to look
into whether the investigation into
Hillary's server was rigged he's going
to look into potential FISA abuse he's
going to look into the origins of this
probe we know that dorm is now
interviewed steel for nearly 16 hours we
know the IG is very close to a FISA
report what do you why is it important
to get to the bottom of this from your
perspective because this should never
happen to another president of the
United States again this is a absolute
catastrophe for our country this was a
fake witch-hunt and it should never be
allowed to happen to another president
again this was treason this was high
crimes this was everything as bad a
definition as you want to come up with
this should never be allowed to happen
to our country again your thoughts
you've often said fake news I called
them out often on this program turns out
there's been you know I I give a list
starting with Richard Jewell and
Ferguson Missouri and Cambridge police
and Baltimore Maryland and UVA and Duke
Lacrosse and Nicholas and man but they
went with every single lie every
conspiracy theory I don't see the media
very often talking about the things you
have accomplished I mentioned the
employment situation is the best since
1969 what do you say to the press in
this country the press that is supposed
to be fair balanced objective down the
middle I'm a talk show host I unlike the
whole newspaper we do everything well I
think the press has lost all credibility
much of it but it's lost a big part of
itself I mean a very substantial part of
it lost all credibility and I watch as
people scream at these
for Democrats the congressmen scream
like I've never seen you must do this
you must do that I mean these are
supposed to be journalists talk-show
hosts all sorts of people I cannot
believe it and they're actually trying
to force them to do what they want to be
done I've never seen anything like it
and I've seen it there you know they use
the word unhinged
they are unhinged the media has become
totally unhinged they're very dishonest
and when I say enemy of the people
when people give purposely false stories
and when they try and get politicians to
do things that are wrong and they know
they're wrong that really is the enemy
of the people it's fake news but it's
the enemy of the people more importantly
in other words that if you're claiming
to be fair balanced objective and now in
the middle and you purposely lie and you
don't have any interest in the truth you
make a distinction between the two and
I've heard you say that many times I'm
interested in this question because you
were very critical of Muller the whole
issue of whether or not you had told
your counsel to to fire him you had the
authority according to Alan Dershowitz
many constitutional attorneys I've
interviewed under article 2 for
conflicts of interest you could have
fired Mahler yourself but my question is
now that you saw how little he actually
knew do you have a different opinion of
him did you at any point almost feel
sorry for him during this so I had the
absolute right to fire him but I didn't
and I never suggested to do it but I had
the absolute right to fire him under
Article two and perhaps for other
reasons but I didn't do it I didn't do
any of the that you know when they say
he said he was going to do this or said
he was gonna die didn't do any of it and
it's really incredible when I hear this
and you know the whole concept of
obstruction first of all they create a
phony crime which was just a terrible
thing to say about somebody especially
somebody that loves the country as much
as I do
so they creates his phony crime and then
they say he obstructed they said there
was no collusion but he obstructed and
there has never been anything like
this ever before in our country this
crime was a the crime was committed on
the other side and we'll find out about
that we have a great attorney general
who's looking at it I'm not involved in
that he's he's looking at it and you
know I've been hearing a lot of the
media actually is talking about
investigate the investigators and a lot
more than that and I think that things
are I just see it I feel it I think a
lot of good is going to come out of it I
we went through hell a lot of people
went through hell they came down to
Washington wanting to do a phenomenal
job for the people and they get served
with papers to come and testify and go
before grand jurors there by the way
nothing affected the trouble you know
all of these things like the Russian
bloggers they had nothing to do with us
and everybody knew it in fact there's a
little sentence and they're saying that
it had nothing to do with the Trump
administration but it was like a lot of
people twenty-four people or something a
lot of bloggers bloggers in Russia
they'll never see these people they know
that they sent out papers to these
people they'll never see them the people
probably never even got the papers but
all of these people none of them had
they went through people with old tax
cases old cases cases that were not even
going forward and you know just went
after them viciously and violently
general Flynn who's a good man what they
did to general Flynn and so many others
hope Hicks is wonderful young woman and
she spent much of her time in Washington
fighting off you know horrible stories
and things and she's just a high quality
person so many I mean I could name I
could name almost everybody what they
went through and still to this day I
mean I heard people saying that I heard
some of the media saying that they
thought Muller performed okay in other
words they let a day go by and then
they'll try and spin it these are very
dishonest people these are very bad
people it's the president the power of
the pardon
I actually think the best part you gave
is to Alice Marie Johnson I think he
commuted her sentence to be more
accurate is absolute have you at any
point ever considered in the back your
mind a pardon for any of the people you
mentioned or you would wait I think you
had said at one point you wouldn't
consider it until after it all worked
through well I don't want to comment on
that as far as the pardons are concerned
yes it is absolute and it's a beautiful
thing I've I've had people jack johnson
the heavyweight champion of the world in
the early 1900s and he went to jail for
you no no no reason and so many other
things and Alice Johnson is another good
example and you know I I really feel
good about giving it where people have
been treated unfairly and abuse actually
but I I haven't talked about it with
respect to what's going on now I mean
it's it's you know whip I think there's
a whole new day starting I think you
know I used to use and I still use drain
the swamp we have some very very bad
people in government that would be
willing to do very bad things and for
bad reasons so I don't mention pardon
but you know I don't say what's going to
happen in the future
I just don't comment on it mr. president
on last question on this and I want to
switch to 2020 if I may call me mccabe
of Comey signed the first FISA warrant
which opened the door apparently
according to newness and the Grassley
grand memo the bulk of information was
Hillary's bought and paid for dirty
Russian dossier and we found out from
John Solomon last week that they had a
spreadsheet even the FBI in early 2017
said ninety-seven percent of this thing
was false garbage not true call me
though signed it that allowed a backdoor
through Carter page to spy on your
campaign later transition and then
presidency but McCain struck page
Brennan clapper may be sourcing out what
would be illegal intelligence gathering
and we know the Attorney General is
there would know is there any of these
names what do you think of these people
because James Comey signed the first
fives of application in October 2016
went to Trump Tower in January 2017 and
told you it's unverified months earlier
he swore on that on that application the
Phi's application that it's verified so
he lied what are your thoughts about
these people today
well Comey is a liar and a linker and
that's obvious and all you have to do is
just follow him along and see what he
said to Congress clapper and Brennan and
all of these people McCabe these are bad
people my opinion they're very bad
people
they've been very bad for the country
they were I used to think incompetent
but they're really I guess competent
that other things and maybe maybe bad
things but you will see what happens I
mean I guess a lot of things are coming
out and it's going to be very
interesting and it will be great to
clean up a real big mess because again
it can never happen this can never be
allowed to happen again Shawn mr.
president you have the power to
literally release device' applications
in the 302s and the gang of eight
information and you made a decision to
hand it over to the Attorney General and
let him decide and I'm curious as to why
well we have a very respected gentleman
a very high quality person named William
Bar and he's doing his I can tell you
he's working so hard and rather than
just doing a total release I gave I gave
him a total release in other words he's
got everything anything he needs he's
got he's the Attorney General of the
United States he's got a lot of very
good people under him that I guess are
involved and I gave them a total release
so all of it's been released and he has
all of it I've also given him
authorization to release it to whoever
he wants whether it's his people or
frankly perhaps people like Devin Nunez
who
is a star what he's done and the amount
of suffering he's gone through you know
what they did with him where they tried
to drive him right out of politics and
probably worse than that he's done an
incredible job and so many others I mean
the job they're warriors we've had I'll
tell you the good side of all of this is
the the level of intelligence and
strength and goodness that we've had on
the Republican Party a lot of a Mike not
everybody of course but we've had
tremendous and I say when I say we I'm
talking about the country the country's
had tremendous support from meadows and
Jordan and and Devon Nunez and so many
of the names that were that you saw
yesterday perform so well I mean they
performed so well and they worked so
hard because they saw this was a scam
this was a an illegal takeover as you'd
say in the business world I mean this
was a this was a coup attempt in my
opinion and this is the United States
and we wouldn't stand for it and I
wouldn't stand for it we have some very
great people but we also have some very
bad people and I think they caught them
I believe sir that we have the premier
law enforcement agency in the world are
FBI we have the premier intelligence
people in the world but that's 99
percent but the one percent at the top
are the ones we're talking about abusing
power
all right so how closely you paying
attention to the 20 20 Democrats that by
the way seem most influenced by the
squad and all of them having even
adopted some version of the insane new
Green Deal that would get rid of the
lifeblood of our economy oil gas and you
know planes and cows and the combustion
engine well you know it's very
interesting because I haven't seen it at
all for the last four or five days
they're not talking about the Democrats
are talking about Muller and how bad he
performed how badly he performed and
they're talking about everything that
happened over the last few days but in
particular yesterday you're not seeing
much about the Democrats but look you
know you've got a few of them that are
doing a little bit better than others
it'll be interesting whoever
I'm okay with it we have the best
economy we've ever had as you know we
have the best stock market numbers we've
ever had in the history of our country
and that's you know if you look at 401ks
if you look at the kind of money that
people are making I'm not talking about
rich people or just rich people I'm
talking about everybody and blue-collar
workers went up proportionately more
than anybody you saw that poll that just
came out things are doing great the best
unemployment numbers the best employment
numbers tell you what more people
working in the United States today than
at any time in the history of our
country and then we have the lowest
unemployment numbers especially for
african-americans for Hispanics for
Asians women are almost 70 years the
best numbers and soon to be historic
meaning forever for meaning from from
the beginning now I think we're gonna be
in great chances then you know you have
then you have the AFC I caught a RC plus
three who do you think wins the three
hangers-on wins the nominating I really
believe they're gonna hurt the Democrats
but who knows I mean we'll see but I
think we're gonna do very well sure I
think we're gonna do very well we have
tremendous spirit every time you've
never seen an empty seat we're going to
these massive arenas and they're packed
and there's thousands of people outside
you've never seen an empty seat so I
think we're going to do very well all
right three quick questions and I'm
going to let you go because I've been
very generous for the time who do you
think wins and will you tell us and is
there one of the group of Democratic
hopefuls that you hope wins because you
know you can beat them easily well you
know I could say that obviously the top
three or four looked like they're doing
better than the rest so sleepy Joe is
okay but he's fading I think he's fading
fast the only good thing about Muller is
it made Joe Biden look like a dynamo so
when you watched motors performance
yesterday I think probably Biden is the
one who's asked him to go on so you have
him and he's sort of a little bit
leading and then you have you have a
whole group you have Elizabeth Warren
formerly known as poker
and I'm sure that'll come out because
that's a tough thing for her to with and
I believe because her whole life was a
fake she used that very very adeptly and
it was not good and you have Harris and
Bernie looks like he's fading to me
Bernie looks like he missed this time I
think you know what Hillary did a few
years ago was it was pretty tough
frankly for Bernie
yes but that was this time this I don't
think it's Bernie's time I see him
flailing he's flailing all over the
place is going crazy I call him crazy
Bernie but the fact is that I think
those would be probably the three or
four maybe there's another one or two
and you know I don't I don't necessarily
see anybody else gaining traction with
the president last two questions first
one is on both Iran and North Korea have
recently fired test missiles here's my
question for you I I think I I've known
you for over nearly 25 years I know your
mindset on this very well I said it on
the air in a message to the mullahs that
they better be careful you will not put
boots on the ground you you probably are
going to show some level of patience but
at the end of the day if they force you
I believe knowing you might believe is
you will devastate them and North Korea
you've given them nothing people
criticize I said certain things I
believe about Donald Trump one you will
put no boots on the ground you will
never try and bribe a dictator like
Clinton did with North Korea and like
Biden Obama did with the mullahs and I
do believe that it pushed the military
might you it unleash will be mighty and
it won't require boots on the ground am
i right well I think that in the case of
Iran they know that better than even you
do and probably even stronger than you
said it I think they understand that
very well and in the case of North Korea
I'm actually getting along very well
with him but we'll see what happens I
mean you know the sanctions are wrong
the hostages are back we're getting the
remains back they haven't done nuclear
testing they really haven't tested
missiles other than you know smaller
ones the
which is something that lots test but I
think with North Korea we've been doing
very well but that doesn't mean it's
going to continue we have a relationship
President Obama had no relationship you
would have been at war had Hillary
Clinton won this election you'd be at
war right now with North Korea and I
have no doubt about that that's where I
was heading it was heading there very
rapidly so as I said well what happens
but I think what you said might be
somewhat of an understatement last
question mr. president and I have said
many times this program all you've given
Kim jong-un is your time and yeah we got
remains back we got hostages back and
missiles stopped up until fairly
recently and you just gave time let me
ask this is maybe it's because it's New
York and I know a city that you
obviously love a lot and you've seen and
you watch with us these police officers
being pounded with water and not
reacting I I and to me if this continues
that is a disastrous situation for the
people in New York City well it's a bad
mayor probably the worst mayor in the
history of New York City he's done a bad
job and now he's running for president
that people can't even believe it he's
horrible mayor
the policeman just and women cannot
stand him they don't respect him they
don't like him remember they turned
their back at him a couple of years ago
when he got up to speak everybody turned
their back and they kept it that way and
still they want to do it but they still
have respect for the office if not him
yeah well as the president I thought
that was tragic watching that scene a
couple of days ago when I first saw it I
couldn't believe it I said let me see
that again I don't believe what I'm
seeing and I know New York's finest and
New York's finest fact we were in touch
with him today they are devastated that
frankly that that could happen and also
that those two offices would allow that
to happen that was a terrible thing
well I we've been at every single one
that we have on video I'd like to see
arrested mr. president won't take any
more your time thank you so much for
being with us as always we really
appreciate it sir
Thank You Sean thank you very much thank
you